Colten yes hi
premiere episode you washed it back with
all of us was there a moment that you
loved and a moment that made you cringe
what was that a moment that I loved I
was just the whole I love the whole
thing really yeah really Colton I did
okay I enjoyed the whole entire thing
because I was my first time like
watching him back with you guys so
there's a lot of fun and then
cringe-worthy mm-hmm I don't know I'm
over critical of myself so probably
something I did yeah in the teaser we
see you crying quite a bit yeah does
that make you uncomfortable watching you
back um it just
it definitely resurfaces some emotions
um because it yeah during that time I
got emotional yeah there's a moment in
the teaser where we see you jumping over
the fence were you done with the show
you know in that moment I had to get
away and yeah I left the show for my
time to just sort of recompose myself
yeah how long was that we talked in 10
minutes
hour weeks um I mean I don't want to
give anything away and I don't want you
guys to take things out of context so
you're gonna have to exactly see what I
mean by jumping over the fence and
leaving the show okay so this season of
The Bachelor they're really focusing on
the virginity aspect yeah how does that
make you feel um you know it is a small
part of who I am so I understand why
it's important and it's important in a
relationship to talk about um you know
and it's not just the show it's other
people you know it's it's a attention
grabber and people throw it in that in
the headlines and unfortunately it's a
label that people want to attach to me
now and there's so much more to me than
that and I'm really looking forward to
everybody getting a better understanding
of who I am and finding out more things
than just the fact that you know I have
my virginity
um do you regret sharing that at all is
that something that you're like oh I
kind of wish I didn't mention it you
know I don't and everybody I say like
really you don't know like no I mean
that's part of who I am I'm just like
sharing the fact I love dogs I
my family I have different things that
make me into the human being I am I like
that one thing you learned about
yourself and one misconception one thing
that I still have a ton of room to grow
that's something that I definitely
learned about myself a misconception as
far as what just you know I know that
you're on Twitter and you were live
tweeting for the premiere episode and
I'm sure people are throwing a lot of
things at you is there one thing or one
theme in particular that you're like god
people don't seem to really get me
there's this one thing that they keep
bringing up yeah that I'm more than a
virgin I mean just as far as you know
misconceptions go I'm not here to prove
anybody you know right wrong or have to
have to prove myself anymore and I think
for the longest time I felt like I
always had something to prove I've
always had a chip on my shoulder I like
to have a playful banter sometimes on
social media and I don't want that to
come off as defensive but yeah yeah are
you in love now I love a lot of things
as far as my love life goes I think
that's what this is all about and I
can't wait like I said to be with there
with you and watch this whole thing play
out 30 women came out of different forms
of transportation 29 women one sloth
okay yes one slot bingo there's so many
women and they're all so beautiful what
captures Colton's attention I would just
say especially on the first night and as
far as first impression goes connection
and chemistry
yeah and just owning who you are and
having that sense of engagement in the
conversation is so comforting mm-hmm
Bree came out with an Australian accent
at what point did you realize she was an
Australian we sat down and had a
conversation and immediately she dropped
it it's like oh well part of me I was
like oh who's really cool to have an
Australian you know on the show and all
of a sudden like oh man okay alright and
then I was like a little relieved yeah
so okay so see you're in love now I have
lots of love for things right okay and
you're not a virgin anymore and the
virginity is what
you're in love right I mean you have a
glow I don't know if it's moisturizer
but I see how it's Jergens I were the
self-tanner of the lotions so shout out
to jurgens Jergens I hope you make a
country album that's what I'm waiting
here to have you heard me sing
no can you say nope have you seen me
dance no I can't do any of them nothing
like a talented mm-hmm that was pretty
good that was like that was like a good
pitch I was giving you a church-like
thank you I'm gonna have my own record
deal by the end of this I think so
I mean reckon baby let's do thank you
happy okay yes me too I hope I'm happy
too I can't wait to see how this turns
out it's gonna be so exciting yeah no
more like crying come on you like we're
gonna yeah we're concerns I know it
makes me feel sad I know it makes me sad
to have to cry okay